germi collective alias ben afan basta
est un jeune de 16 ans de pendule est au
nunavut où il est inouï tu es aspirants
m6 met à sa première expérience sur
scène lors d'un concert à bike à 8
jérémy a eu un blanc de mémoire
et
m
et puis moi baden et nous quitte en bas
âge et les glissements wanadoo mal en
point
et jeremy n'est pas le seul à perdre ses
mots c'est le cas de beaucoup de jeunes
d'aujourd'hui dans l'arctique et comme
jeremy il les perdent en une petite août
environ 150 milles inuit fils dans le
cercle polaire arctique
ils sont répartis entre l'alaska le
canada le groenland et la russie mais
dans la plupart des communautés de moins
en moins de jeunes parlent la langue
inuit au canada cette langue est
communément appelée lino petit doute sur
le territoire canadien du nunavut les
inuit forme environ les trois quarts de
la population
ce qui n'empêche pas les outils tout de
se limiter à bien des endroits un rôle
de second plan une multitude dé
découvrir les raisons qui expliquent le
déclin de lino petits tout au canada et
dans d'autres régions du nord sont
complexes
pendant la plus grande partie du 20ème
siècle les politiques gouvernementales
dans la majorité des régions de
l'arctique vise l assimilation des
inuits dans la culture occidentale
lusage de ligne petit tout est la
plupart du temps des conseillers
aujourd'hui les professeurs d'une petite
août se font rares et la culture
occidentale du sud continue de s'imposer
un peu partout dans l'arctique
mais certains politiciens et expert en
linguistique identifient une autre cause
à la perte de vitesse de ligne petit
tout la surabondance de dialectes
différents
c'est que lino petit tout ne fait pas
que varier d'une région à l'autre à
l'intérieur même du cercle polaire
arctique ligne petites huttes varie
aussi selon les communautés
il y à une multitude de prononciation
d'expression
moi
et d'orthographe ce qui veut dire que
des inuit de régions différentes doivent
souvent avoir recours à l'anglais pour
se parler à titre d'exemple cette
assemblée d'inuits de l'alaska du canada
et du groenland où même les interprètes
professionnels réunis sur place avaient
du mal à s'ajuster à tous les dialectes
à sicap couac technique
plusieurs experts en linguistique disent
qu'il faut que ça change
ils veulent standardisés l'orthographe
inuit et éventuellement créer aussi un
dialecte inuit standard qui pourraient
être utilisés et compris par les inuit
d'un bout à l'autre de l'arctique jose
kusugak est un chef inuit influent de
rankin inlet au nunavut est un ancien
maître d'école sur non mais c'est une
solution controversée beaucoup d'inuits
craignent qu'on standardisant la langue
beaucoup de dialectes locaux vont
disparaître assez de passe
oui tout est clean est une linguiste de
l'hérault en alaska la langue inuit de
cette région s'appelle linou pjak
elle milite pour la création de normes
d'écriture inuit commune depuis les
années 70 au début peu de gens appuyer
sa démarche
mais depuis que le réchauffement
climatique et la mondialisation menace
la culture inuit
elle croit qu'une langue commune
pourrait bien constituer la meilleure
défense
so in the sound le strom mieux connu
sous le nom de moscou est le metteur en
scène et concepteur de théâtre le plus
prisé du groenland
il soutient le point de vue des gens
comme et dynamique les piquer un peu
vain de shipshaw windsurf ou non
mais même si tous s'entendaient sur la
nécessité de créer un dialecte et une
écriture commune
il resterait tout de même un long chemin
à parcourir quel dialecte doit-on
choisir et qui doit prendre cette
décision
zacharias kunuk est un cinéaste
d'igloolik au nunavut
il a remporté des prix à travers le
monde pour ses films tournés en hymne
aux petits tout il croit que son succès
est la preuve que la culture inuit peut
s'épanouir sans le recours à un dialecte
comme man and work will do en renault
clio la radio
even in future forme shabani de gaza
carayos kunuk crois que les linguistes
s'engage dans une lutte difficile s'ils
veulent standardiser la langue inuit au
canada encore faudra-t-il y arriver à
travers l'arctique
aller a ajouté mme hinse ap de rap est
une chose mais en dépit des
préoccupations
il existe pourtant bien un endroit dans
l'arctique où la langue inuit a été
standardisés et n'a cessé de gagner en
force depuis ce changement
cet endroit c'est le groenland
l'ancienne colonie danoise compte
aujourd'hui environ 50000 inuit
ici la langue s'appelle le cas là la
soute ou encore le groenland et en
français
le groenlandais a été standardisés dans
les années soixante dix la langue est
maintenant visible par tous les
dialectes régionaux continuent d'être
parlée à la maison mais la langue
standard est ce que les groenlandais
utilise pour communiquer entre eux les
magazines et les journaux sont publiés
en groenlandais les graffitis sont en
groenlandais et même la musique rêver
métal punk rap et oui elle aussi en
groenlandais
plusieurs croient que le groenland
devrait servir de modèle pour ce qui
pourrait un jour devenir possible à
travers tout l'arctique
peter loubert tu vis à nuuk la capitale
du groenland le jour il est éducateur
dans une garderie mais le soir il est
connu sous le pseudonyme de pin d'elle
l'un des rappeurs les plus connus du
groenland
il part régulièrement en tournée en
europe ou dans d'autres parties de
l'arctique
il dit qu'il ne peut pas s'imaginer
performer dans une autre langue que la
sienne
christiansen mieux connu sous le nom de
pouilloux et linguiste et le chef du
secrétariat de la langue groenlandaise
il s'agit de l'organisme qui autorise
les nouveaux usages vocabulaire ou
terminologie de la langue groenlandaise
il dit que la standardisation de la
langue inuit permet à des artistes
groenlandais comme puis un dell ne pas
avoir à se tourner vers le danois ou
l'anglais pour participer à la culture
contemporaine
pour lui c'est là le moyen de garder la
motivation des jeunes à paris la langue
inuit
la sérénade en pleine de bruit le qatar
l'ingouchie cet espace va intégrer 10
par rapport aux cultures et aux ors d'un
grossiste date heure là qui s'intitule
comment pour faire mouche de music hall
and two to understand calcio en aiguille
wineries d'abord le pentagone indique
the great stand écrit n'indique en
terres publiques il faut prendre et il
s'est jointe au fond qu'une indiquent
des rechutes imité par essence aux
ouailles au daily show the life of the
youth des accords de schengen et sansot
appelé à commenter
il faut tuer
de retour au canada jose kusugak crois
que ce qui se produit au groenland est
l'illustration de ce que
l'uniformisation de la langue peut
apporter à la culture inuit
il espère que les inuits de l'article
vont adopter une position commune sur la
langue avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
mais on le sait la minute où tu vas pas
simple
et le débat continue mais en attendant à
ical witt
voyons plutôt ce qui est arrivé à johnny
collective après les quelques ratés de
son premier concert rap et bien à la fin
du concert pind elle a évité tous les
autres rappeurs sur scène
mise à improviser en groenlandais même
chose pour le rappeur d'un hélico puis
on a tendu le micro à jeremy est une
chose très intéressante s'est produite
au 9 bis des confidences floue entre
east
mais personne ne semblait plus surpris
que johnny lui même au naturel tous des
nuls titeuf
et verwoerd mais quand on lui demande de
faire le bilan de son expérience
je lui préfère laisser parler les
paroles c'est parole mais timoteï me
moving à adjamé attaque n'était pas une
belle finale motown système ok rock tome
1 1 milliard à tous et n'eurent pas
c'est une manne n'est pas jean à nous
rassure tout à côté qu'elle n'arrêtait
manager mama i'm gonna pia